ganz genau vielen dank thomas während
die beiden männer über den cdu-vorsitz
gesprochen haben bin ich rüber als
unserem touchscreen gegangen denn unser
nächstes thema ist corona auch darüber
müssen wir heute sprechen die zahlen
sind auf dem vormarsch und die frage
natürlich liebe zuschauer steht uns ein
harter corona winter bevor und wir
wollen jetzt im detail gucken was ich
ihnen an dieser stelle jetzt schon
verraten kann ist die zahlen sind zur
vorwoche um 3,2 prozent gestiegen hört
sich erstmal nicht viel an aber wir
gucken jetzt nochmal wie gesagt im
detail fangen wir an auf unserem chor
ohne radar mit den co
neuansteckungen in deutschland von heute
vom 2 november
2021 da liegen wir heute bei genau 10
1813 patienten die sich ganz neu mit
cuna infiziert haben und sie sehen auch
hier liebe zuschauer dieses tal dieses
loch da befanden wir uns natürlich im
sommer und seit dem herbst geht es nach
oben hier ein kleiner schwank nach unten
und dann wieder steil nach um vor fünf
tagen waren wir schon mal höher als
heute da lang der ungefähr bei
28.000 neuansteckungen an einem tag auch
hier sind wir gerade wieder etwas nach
unten gegangen wir schauen mal auf die
patienten die sich aktuell in den
krankenhäusern befinden insgesamt sind
das 2000 67 19 patienten davon mehr als
die hälfte mit
1072 werden beatmet und
995 werden nicht beatmet liegen daher
auch nicht auf der intensivstation wir
schauen uns auch mal die karte von
deutschland an auch ganz interessant was
wir hier sehen die
krankenhausbetten sind vor allem im
norden sehr stark belegt hier im westen
süden osten nimmt es ein wenig ab woran
das genau liegt kann ich ihnen auch im
moment nichts sagen aber so sieht es
momentan in deutschland aus wir schauen
auch nochmal auf die intensivbetten in
ganz deutschland freie betten sind noch
da und zwar
3595 insgesamt gemeldete betten in
deutschland 24
1783 das bedeutet natürlich auch die
belegten betten mit 21.100 88 sind nicht
nur cupid 19 patienten sondern natürlich
auch alle anderen erkranken mit
eingerechnet die korona patienten sehen
wir hier auch nochmal mit
2067 und ein letzter blick noch auf die
todesfälle da liegen wir am heutigen tag
den zweiten november bei 81 toten auch
hier sehen wir die tendenz leicht
steigend zum sommer hin aber natürlich
immer noch längst nicht so heftig wie
wir damals im winter
2020 gestartet sind soweit die
aktuellsten zahlen ist von unserem
cholera da und damit zu dir ja design
die zahlen steigen also wieder was tun
für gesundheitsminister sparen ist die
sache klar wir brauchen
auffrischimpfungen sowie israel es
beispielsweise wieder einmal vorgemacht
hat wo die infektionszahlen nach den
booster impfungen wieder deutlich
gesunken sind sparen gestern auf einem
internationalen kongress in englisch
bereit
israel hat der welt gezeigt wie wichtig
es ist
umfangreich ist da schon die guided wir
sollten uns vom beispiel israels
ziele von denen geht es jetzt nicht
irren verliefen nicht mehr überzeugt
werden
umso wichtiger ist es dass alle anderen
geschützt bleiben wir sollten uns auf
einen sicheren winter vorbereiten und
wie gesagt israel
und in einem interview mit der
rheinischen post sandra ist zurück schön
mit der rheinischen post erklärte spahn
auch kurzerhand wie die booster kampagne
verwirklicht werden soll wir schauen mal
auf das zitat um möglichst vielen
möglichst schnell eine auffrischimpfung
zu ermöglichen sollten die länder die
impfzentren die sie seit ende september
im standby bereithalten nun wieder
startbereit machen was der
bundesgesundheitsminister da aber
offenbar nicht berücksichtigt ist die
meisten impfzentren sind überhaupt nicht
mehr im standby modus sondern sie sind
wieder abgebaut worden wie soll das also
funktionieren und wie viele impfzentren
gibt es überhaupt noch das weiß nicht
mal in seinem eigenen ministerium der
sprecher wir haben mal was er sagt
ich muss ehrlich gestehen dazu liegen
mir keine zahlen vor da die bundesländer
die impfzentren in eigener zuständigkeit
betreiben ich weiß dass wir in
ich meine soll im juni juli dieses
jahres
um die 400 ins zentrum hatten wie viele
davon jetzt aber noch in betrieb sind
das kann kann ich nicht sein aber dafür
gibt es ja uns in liebe zuschauer wir
haben ganz genau recherchiert und haben
jetzt konkrete zahlen für sie parat
schauen wir mal rein bis zum sommer gab
es zum beispiel in in sechs zentren in
bayern 100 in sachsen 13 in
schleswig-holstein
28 impfzentren ja und jetzt zum
vergleich der aktuelle stand von denen
rund bundesweit 430 aus dem sommer sind
insgesamt nur noch 12 geöffnet in berlin
bremen und rheinland-pfalz ja und die in
rheinland pfalz insgesamt neun der zwölf
sind auch nur auf standby
philipp der vorschlag also des
bundesgesundheitsministers einigermaßen
realitätsfremd naja also wie unsere
gesamte politik gerade also ehrlich
gesagt mir macht nicht der anstieg der
infektionszahlen sorge sondern wie immer
eigentlich die reaktion der politik dann
dass die zahlen steigen werden im herbst
das wusste jeder hat jeder experte und
sogar jeder laie wusste dass wenn die
grippesaison kommt dann fuhr sie nun mal
wieder die atemwegserkrankung dann kommt
auch crooner zurück war völlig klar dass
man sich darauf vorbereiten muss und
andere länder impfen nun mal wie israel
aber auch wie großbritannien zum dritten
mal und das sehr erfolgreich und auch
sehr viel schneller als wir und unsere
politik begibt sich wieder mal in
gewisse widersprüche auf der einen seite
rufen zum beispiel politiker wie markus
söder der bayerische ministerpräsident
dazu auf dass möglichst viele menschen
alle menschen am liebsten sich zum
dritten mal impfen lassen sollen auf der
anderen seite schaffen wir es aber nicht
diejenigen die es wirklich brauchen also
die älteren die vor erkranken die
immunschwachen zuerst mal zu impfen also
die politik will mal sehr viel aber
schaffte es nicht das zu tun was sie
eigentlich machen sollte und die booster
impfung auch das sagen alle sie brauchen
vor allem jene die ein schwaches
immunsystem haben deren impfschutz im
laufe der monate stark nachgelassen hat
da sind die menschen die jetzt auch
wieder erkranken auch wenn sie doppelt
geld sind aber diese booster impfung ist
ja jetzt auch er seit ein paar wochen in
aller munde wusste man das nicht
vielleicht auch vorher dass man da
einfach die impfzentren nicht abbaut und
einfach stehen lässt um zu sagen hey wir
brauchen tatsächlich diese dritte
impfung bald also lasst uns das ding
stehen lassen lasst uns auch die leute
hier behalten weil wir brauchen es ja
absolut also die booster impfung ist
vielleicht erst seit einigen wochen in
aller munde aber politik die sich ja
auch austauscht mit der wissenschaft
sollte etwas mehr wissen und da wusste
man auch schon vor weit über
ein paar wochen dass das auf uns zukommt
dass wir auch zum dritten mal impfen
werden und man wusste ja auch noch mehr
man wusste dass man es nicht schaffen
wird alle erwachsenen menschen überhaupt
bis zum herbst also eigentlich sollte
man diese option diese möglichst leichte
optionen sich ohne termin oder den
hausarzt einfach irgendwo reinzulaufen
sich eine impfung zu holen die hätte man
vielleicht einfach beibehalten sollen
klar vielleicht nicht mit über 400
impfzentren vielleicht braucht ist oder
hat es das nicht mehr gebraucht aber das
mittlerweile nur noch ein dutzend im
zentrum in ganz deutschland offen sind
und auch niemand weiß wie viele in
standby sind und wie viele komplett
abgebaut sind dass der sprecher des
gesundheitsministeriums nicht weiß wie
viele impfzentren ist in deutschland
gerade gibt das ist dieses klassische
datenklaus wir wissen seit anderthalb
jahren nicht wie viel getestet wird wie
hoch die inzidenz wirklich ist wie viele
menschen geimpft haben und die
bundesregierung weiß nicht mehr wie
viele impfzentren es gibt wenig
verstecken sich ja nicht also ein im
zentrum zu registrieren ist jetzt
wirklich nicht das allerschwerste von
der welt dass bei 60 millionen impfungen
nicht jeder registriert wird dafür kann
ich noch irgendwie verständnis
aufbringen aber dass man nicht weiß wie
viele impfzentren ist noch gibt meine
güte das sind riesige dinge zumal die
gesundheitsminister der länder ja schon
vor längerem dazu aufgerufen haben die
booster impfungen nicht nur für über 60
oder 70 jährige sondern breitflächig
anzubieten und auch die ständige
impfkommission prüft jetzt ob diese
booster impfungen auch schon für ab 40
jährigen beispielsweise angeboten werden
soll das heißt man wusste dass da was
auf die impfzentren zukommen wird
absolut man wusste es da muss ich
allerdings kritisch einen haken wenn man
mit experten spricht sagen die es ist
nicht so dass jeder hat wird sich jetzt
eine booster impfung braucht bei vielen
menschen unter 40 über 40 reichten zwei
impfungen aus um wirklich einen
effektiven impfschutz zu garantieren das
problem sind diejenigen die etwas älter
sind die vor krank sind bei denen der
impfschutz nach einigen monaten
nachlässt und da adamek die politik
ehrlich gesagt gerade auch wenn sie sich
noch nicht traut auszusprechen dass sie
mit 2g und 3g auf dem komplett falschen
dampfer ist aber andererseits zeigt das
beispiel israel ja weil das wir
gesprochen haben jens spahn hat es ja
auch erwähnt dass dort innerhalb weniger
wochen die inzidenz wieder
heruntergefahren werden konnten auf
jetzt aktuell 50
die seit diese booster impfungen
angeboten werden ich weiß nicht ob das
mit der booster impfung zu tun hatte
also ehrlich gesagt die booster impfung
hilft vor allem dabei ältere menschen zu
schützen also die beiden der impfschutz
gesunken ist womit der inzidenz abfalls
zu tun hat ob das wirklich an der
booster impfung liegt das weiß ich noch
nicht das werden vermutlich künftig die
studien zeigen aber wir sehen ja kona in
der ganzen welt als in form einer welle
also mal steigen die zahlen mal sinken
sie und man weiß nicht immer genau woran
es liegt die politik versucht immer
diese eine passende erklärung zu liefern
die jetzt gerade zur politischen agenda
passt nach dem motto wir haben die
schulen geschlossen dann sagten die
zahlen wir haben ausgangssperren
verhängt oder wie bundes notbremse
dagegen die zahlen runter und dann
stellte sich später heraus dass hatte
nichts damit zu tun also würde man
einfach auch mal dahin kommen nicht
einfach inflationär einfach impfen zu
wollen zu müssen ein zwei- dreimal
sondern auch zu gucken wer braucht die
impfung wirklich wie viel antikörper hat
mein körper gebildet das müsste
eigentlich auch mittlerweile damit rein
spielt sozusagen allein die tatsache
dass wir hier stehen und darüber
diskutieren was könnte denn jetzt seien
und wie sieht es vielleicht aus zeigt
dass die kommunikation jedenfalls
seitens der politik nicht funktioniert
vielen dank für den moment